is it cold in here I'm so cold we went
out of my dad's yacht last night for
like eight hours and I'm just like still
ya know I don't even do anything to my
hair it just looks this good natural you
have to leave early today I have to go
to the consulate or wherever to get more
pages for my passport apparently it's so
hard to go Jean shopping because all the
jeans is just they need to tighten up
tellurian super hot but like I gotta
sleep you know I can't have sex all the
time yeah so I take my sailboat out with
my family on Sunday and we didn't even
see one whale we saw a shark but that
was scary yeah I got invited to all
these Oscar parties again it's just
annoying because like I don't have that
many dresses uh I had to turn down
tickets to see it louis c.k because i've
backstage passes me taylor swift I'm
gonna tell you my email and got hacked
yeah so like Ryan Philippe just got spam
for me
right so how do I know the boss just
took me out to lunch because I've been
doing such a great job and he bought me
drinks now I'm drunk I can't even do
anywhere I'm so hungry I have to eat so
much I just my metabolism so fast and
it's just like I have to keep feeding it
like I wish that I get gained weight but
I just can't
[Music]
[Music]